I did a little video teasing a morning
routine guy okay and it kind of sent me
down a rabbit hole like what o what else
cuz my point in the video my point in
the video was morning routines used to
be endearing right you know you look at
some of them and it's just some corny
guy who
goes as a CEO of a multi-million dollar
company the first thing I do when I get
up in the morning is make my bed MH and
like it's like this epic edit of him
making his bed you know and then you
know or it'll be like a guy's like I
like to have you know coffee and then go
to the gym at 7 a.m. like all the all
the timings were reasonable as well yeah
yeah okay and you know now it's like I
get up at 3:00 and it's all whatever
yeah so there's so many people who are
like I I did Andrew huberman's morning
routine for 60 days dude they these guys
talk about productivity during a certain
period and the things they do in the
morning would definitely shock you awake
it's like cold plunge and then drink
mineral water that tastes like [__] it's
supposed to you know fire you up yeah
but the one the part of it that cracked
me up was then they suggest what this
thing nsdr
nonsleep dick rotations yeah yeah no
what is it it it's
basically uh napping with your eyes open
what and he recommends doing that at 3:
a.m. no no p.m okay uh yeah it nonsleep
deep rest I'm like this okay non-sleep
deep rest he might have a doctor method
of deep relaxation it was developed by
Dr Andrew oh he actually developed it
okay he might be a neuroscientist but
bro this is a
nap this is a nap and I love how these
guys go on and they go yeah so you're
going to get up at 6 and you're going to
you know drink your mineral water and
they have this whole routine set up
between 6 and 10 of drink of cold plunge
looking directly into the sun yeah yeah
working out looking directly into the
sun yeah whatever the hell
and and then from 10 to 2 you do a spec
you do like task oriented work and then
at three to five you do
nsdr which is a
nap and this guy was like you know I
like to lay and close my eyes and listen
to meditative
you know po like exercises but I don't
sleep that's basically sleeping yeah I'm
not I'm I'm I'm not I'm not going to
go I'm awake you know yeah yeah yeah
he's
like yo yo St I've been awake the whole
time I'm been awake the whole ndr ndr I
was not sleeping I was not sleeping why
don't you just nap we here at teamg
Studios have developed a new way of
rejuvenating your afternoon energy we
call it na
P
nonactive um presentation yes you're
you're not actively presenting yeah so
what you're going to do you're just
going to line your back and you're going
to close your eyes and you're not going
to go to sleep you're just going to keep
them closed yeah until you start
drooling yeah and then you wake up I've
been working on this new program that
I'm still like tailoring a little bit
it's an afternoon same sort of thing
like kind of a way to relax and get
energy back I call it j e r k i n g o f
f I call it pounding your [__]
off P
Ys o p yso and this a term I came up
with after studying um it do doing my
thesis at Harvard for my Neuroscience uh
master's degree and um it's
it py py founding your [__] p pyso is
it's really developed from is is
developed from Eastern ideology uh in
eastern ideology they put a lot of
emphasis on meditation and focus and uh
energy how it moves through your body
and all energy is believed to be stored
at the base chakra which is typically
associated with pounding your [__] off
and that's how I came up with
PSO piso works in conjunction with Bido
beating your dick off yeah these are all
programs that have a similar effect are
unique in their own way but work
together cuz when you're pounding your
[__] off it's kind of more like
this cuz well when you're beating your
[__] off it's
like with two very different energies
you know and and two different similar
but you know programs you want to apply
based on the type of work you're doing
you know um so yeah we you know uh as
men in our 30s we' advise
pyso once a week yes cuz um it's
typically very hard to be productive
yeah the the what we call um the slump
off rate is much steeper after 30 yeah
if you pyso you're probably going to p a
SS o u
t one of these videos they're pointing
out a study where
apparently they go
sugar cocaine and something increases
dopamine temporarily by 25% but a cold
plunge is seen to raise your Baseline
200% not true I I was like there's no
way a cold PL true feels as good as
cocaine yeah no doesn't yeah at all you
don't go into a cold plunge and come out
and you're like I'm going to start a
business yeah yeah
exactly I never even done C
but I just know that's what happens on
cocaine I want to start a business yeah
I've done you know I've done the Aderall
[__] it's like it's the same [__]
exactly yeah
know you also you can't do a cold Plunge
in a bathroom with other like people
what do you mean you know oh yeah yeah
exactly yeah it's not like a it's not a
fun social activity yeah you could but
it would be way weirder yeah than doing
is this your cold plunge yeah yeah if I
get you mind if I get some yeah for sure
you cut me a section of
this five dudes damn shit's cold dude my
dopamine is [__] going crazy right
now I got a
sauna I just got it yesterday Barrel
sauna haven't used it yet but I'm stoked
dude I can't wait for you to try it and
you're like I had another anxiety attack
yeah I know that's that [__] actually
sucks ass I'm never going to use it
again have you gotten back in your cold
plunge yet uh no but
I'm pumped for this because a cold
blunch gets much easier if you if you
like heat yourself up like crazy what it
feels good and it doesn't feel like
torturous fair fair so I'm going to get
in the sauna and then get in the coal
plunge and just do that back and forth
right right so that's the new plan which
I'm really stuck for these morning
routines crack me up man as you saw that
tweet where it was
like all these guys have these morning
routines like they're training for war
project managers dude dude yes hold on
be project manager at meta yeah yeah
yeah no this this is a better version of
that I think a bunch of those tweets
been popping off but I think this one is
the best so funny san fran San Francisco
has the highest percentage of people who
need 45 minutes of Comm meditation 25
minutes in an equinox sauna a $17
smoothie and 8 and 1/2 hours of rest in
their e sleep to recover from filing
four jira tickets but also want to leave
this high pressure life and become a
farmer
it's so [__] true isn't it it kills
you man there are guys that go work in
Coal Mines every day and they're [__]
their morning routine is like well I try
to get some water in cuz I drank like 12
last night so it kind of [__] me up
I've been trying to chill out and do
more like 10 a night
but I laugh but I'm the same way dude
yeah I'm like I got to go recover from
this podcast episode yeah and switch
between my sauna and coal plunge for
[__] 4 hours you know how I over open
me in the mind what I drink a coffee
late in the day and then I do a podcast
or I'll do a podcast I drink a coffee
late in the day and then I go play
Counter Strike for exactly one hour yeah
yelling and getting yelled
at and trying to play that game yeah
that over dopamine's my mind for sure
yeah and then I and then our team loses
and then I'm quietly raging the rest of
the day and that makes me really active
yeah yeah yeah yes that's yeah I feel
like over dopamine over dopamin is a bad
thing yeah isn't it you would think yeah
isn't that what Molly
is
yeah that's what Tik Tok is yeah and
that too it's
bad I'm just I'm just over over it's
important it's
important